TRACE DOMINGUEZ: Hey guys
Trace here for Secret Trips.
We're at the
Farnborough Air Show
where they've been N the newest
in plane technology all week.
But without the
legacy of aircraft,
the legacy of aerospace,
we wouldn't be out there.
So we need to remember
these old planes
and how cool they are too.
In order to respect
the power and ingenuity
of modern-day aircraft,
you have to look
to the past, the early
pioneering flying
machines of cloth and
wood, the sleek metal
planes that pushed the limits
of where humans can venture.
The failures, the successes--
each one an important piece
of the puzzle that
has brought us
to where we are today, which
is why many have worked
to preserve these airplanes--
like Tracey Curtis Taylor who
restored and flies a
classic Boeing-Stearman.
She took me on a
tour of her airplane
and gave me a little
insight on why
vintage planes, like her Spirit
of Artemis, are so special.
There must be just
something about these planes
versus-- we're at Farnborough.
So there's new
planes everywhere,
and they're showing off
the newest technology.
But, it just feels
different, I imagine,
to fly something like this.
TRACEY CURTIS TAYLOR:
Well, actually it's
chalk and cheese with the
original pioneering flying.
But what you're seeing here
is a handmade airplane.
This is a wood and
fabric old biplane.
And it's just classic
1920s technology.
Everybody calls
this real flying.
So, again, to take
an airplane like this
around the world flying the
rivers, the lakes, the shore
lines, at low level, this
is probably the best flying
adventure in the world.
And it's very rare now.
This is a bit of a dying art.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: And that
may be the perfect word
to describe these
planes, art-- the way
they're shaped, the way they
fly, the way they sound.
But it's also more than that.
It's about what these
restored airplanes represent
and their place in history.
Obviously you're very
passionate about this.
So when you bring
a plane like this
out to a show like this,
what's the thinking?
What are you trying to
do by bringing it here?
TRACEY CURTIS
TAYLOR: Well, I think
it's rather lovely, because
it's this juxtaposition
of old and new.
And I think this
generation needs
to be reminded that civil
aviation was based, really,
on people like me getting
into wooden fabric airplanes.
These pioneers back
in the 20s and 30s,
these were daring, dashing,
very brilliant individuals who
were really pushing
the boundaries,
taking enormous personal risks,
but out there to prove it
could be done.
And these were the early days.
This is when aviation
was very new, very fresh.
And the whole world was
just fascinated and thrilled
by the idea of flight.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: Walking
around the Farnborough airshow,
it's clear the world is
still fascinated by flight.
And, yes, it is
partly the excitement
of seeing a jet fly by
at unfathomable speeds,
to look at the newest,
biggest, and fastest,
to think about the
next step in aerospace.
But the past will continue
to be an important part
of the present.
Vintage planes
will continue to be
salvaged, restored, remembered,
presented, and, of course,
flown.
And in Tracy's mind, flying
them should be a requirement.
TRACEY CURTIS
TAYLOR: I'd just like
to see an element of training
where people, the students,
the pilots of the future
still get a chance
to fly airplanes like this.
But I have young students coming
and looking at the cockpit
here and just saying, we
don't know how you fly this.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: And I think
keeping them around like this
and getting people to be
able to come and see them
is probably part of that, right.
TRACEY CURTIS TAYLOR: Oh,
it's really important.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ:
And with that, Tracy
took me on a tour of her
historic Boeing-Stearman,
a one-time military
training plane that
retired as a crop duster before
taking Tracy across continents
and oceans.
TRACEY CURTIS TAYLOR:
This is a 1942 Lycoming
engine, 300-horsepower.
It's got a variable
pitch propeller,
so I can change the angle
of the propeller blades--
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: Oh, wow.
TRACEY CURTIS TAYLOR: --for
when I'm climbing or cruising.
The fuel is all up
in the top wing.
But I've had extra fuel tanks
put in, so on either side
there are fill-up
tanks, and I've
got about six hours
endurance here.
This is wood and fabric.
There's four different
types of wood
used in the construction
of the wing.
And all the ribbing
and stitching,
they're all hand-stitched.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: Yeah,
you can see that.
TRACEY CURTIS TAYLOR: So
there's hundreds of man-hours
that have gone into the
making of this airplane.
The undercarriage-- this is a
real tractor of an airplane.
This is what makes
it just so versatile.
All these tensioning
in the wires
they should all strike
a different note.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ:
Oh, wow, so you can
hear them and know whether--
TRACEY CURTIS
TAYLOR: Yeah, I do.
Yeah, I do.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: --or not
they're the right type.
Can I pluck this?
[PLUCKING]
Oh, that's great.
I'm just impressed by
how much engineering
goes into building something
that then comes out
to be just such a simple,
beautiful machine.
TRACEY CURTIS TAYLOR:
That's the old bird.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: Planes
like the Spirit of Artemis
are important.
They are a snapshot to the
past and an inspiration
for the future.
TRACEY CURTIS
TAYLOR: And they're
just so beautiful to look at.
People just get so enthused
by the romance and adventure
of it.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ:
I'm there, for sure.
TRACEY CURTIS TAYLOR: I
wouldn't buy anything else.
TRACE DOMINGUEZ:
Thank you for watching
and make sure to
subscribe for more videos.